they're estimated to be 35 million
people in the US with some level of
motor impairment designing your
application to support accessibility
services not only opens up your
application to these users but it has
the potential to improve your design for
everyone
users with motor impairments have a wide
range of conditions including spinal
cord injuries multiple sclerosis ALS
cerebral palsy essential tremor and
Parkinson's these users may find it
difficult to use a touchscreen
particularly if your app relies on small
touch targets or complex gestures google
has developed the accessibility services
switch access and voice access in order
to provide these users with alternate
means of operating their devices with
switch access users press one or more
physical Hardware buttons to scan
through items on their screen and select
the one they want voice access lets
users speak their commands to the device
in order to tap scroll or enter text ok
Google start voice access go home open
phone click 17 go home tap 8 go back
swipe right by keeping a few design
considerations in mind you can radically
transform the quality of user
interaction between your app and switch
access and voice access a switch access
user usually scans the screen from top
to bottom therefore it's a good idea to
keep elements on the screen logically
organized small touch targets can be
difficult for users to select so we
recommend that touch targets be at least
48 by 48 DP in addition users can have
difficulty interacting with touch
targets that are closely grouped
together therefore we suggest having low
density layouts ensure that clickable
and long clickable items are correctly
labeled and that the clickable attribute
hasn't been added to any non clickable
items you can easily try out switch
access in your own app by going to
settings accessibility switch access
opening switch access settings and then
by assigning a volume key to act as a
switch you can also use a USB or
Bluetooth keyboard
then ensure that you can perform every
action in the app with the switch make
sure that each item can be scrolled
through and it is clear what each one
does to learn more about switch access
or voice access check out these links at
developer.android.com
you should also consider watching our
video on developing for users with
visual impairments
[Music]